hey guys and welcome to another episode
of congratulations
[Music]
we're here we are here we are back with
another episode baby and i have this
stuck in my head
baby shark doo doo doo doo baby shark
doo doo doo doo baby shark doo doo doo
doo doo baby shark
calvin was watching it and he has a
shirt that has a button on it that my
aunt got him and he presses the button
and every time he presses the button on
that shirt that's what it does it's
driving me insane but it's all good
because it makes him happy as [ __ ] and
when he's done he goes more more
and he's just starting to round that r
off afterwards he's starting to go more
more
and it's very very cute and that's it
but um i am definitely getting the baby
shark song stuck in my head so that's
all good and it's fine was a little bit
nauseous the other day and that's all
good and it's fine got through it worked
out worked it out and it's all good
worked out did a lot of [ __ ] crunches
and did some crazy chin-ups sorry strong
guys i broke your hearts and uh we're
off and running dude it's another week
uh in the congratulations world we we're
doing a world dude it's like the [ __ ]
uh what do you call it the avengers the
avengers and the and the marvel universe
that's what it is
it's the uh congratulations junipers
that's what we're gonna do i don't know
how to do the break off characters
though or the side characters because
it's only me always on congratulations
but i'll figure it out somehow somehow
um not some high cause that's not what i
meant to say but uh uh yeah go if you
love supporting the show patreon.com
if you'd love to support the show that's
awesome you get all of the episodes uh
uncut extra
uh episodes a month and uh all without
ads and that's six dollars um
right there just sign up patreon.com or
you can go to merch we got sorry strong
guys we got the worldwide world
worldwide life rips it's very hard to
say we've got the og life rips colorway
uh and all that [ __ ] the tie-dyed [ __ ]
and some hats and it's dude it's just
like i'm a fashionista baby you know
um
what's that thing when it goes change
clothes and
what's the last part never knew never
we'll never know dude when jay-z does it
change clothes and
and
bone and go change clothes and
that's what it is now
change clothes
oh
hove
jay-z laughs like he woke up from a bad
dream
um
so anyway i'm here and uh
and it's all good dude but yeah so
congratulations um
and uh i was [ __ ] i'm dude i've been
let me just tell you this i've been
watching this new show called gamora
it's not new new to me yes dude not new
but new to me it's called gamora and
it's italian it is [ __ ] straight up
italiano and these italians don't [ __ ]
around man i'm telling you right now
this show is so good it's so good
everyone says sopranos is the [ __ ]
best and it is one of the best but dude
i put on gamora and it's about the mafia
in italy and dude i mean this [ __ ]
thing
one first so so the whole first season
three days dude and these [ __ ]
italians bark at each other dude i need
to get more italian man i need to get
way more italian than i am that's the
thing i need to get way more because i'm
you know i'm italian right i'm from
[ __ ] new jersey my dad's from queens
and his dad's from uh bari italy and
it's just dude
i need to get [ __ ] they bark at each
other man they talk so close to
[ __ ] this was before kovid when
they shot this thing but they talked so
close
and they're touching each other they're
practically kissing each other and
that's two men do it and it's so
heterosexual
they really ride that line that
heterosexual homosexual [ __ ] the
italians man and they're all tanned as
[ __ ] and one guy dude this is the
italian bro they make [ __ ] shows that
are so good this show is so good it's
beautiful man even kristen i was
watching with kristen kristen looked
over to me she was like these shots are
really beautiful and dude she's not one
to [ __ ] say that
but this [ __ ] gamora
dude it's so it is so good it's so good
you know what dude i'm gonna tell you
right now it's so good that i followed
the lead actor on instagram and he never
posted anything in english
[Music]
italiano
[ __ ] yeah dude it's so good man you guys
got to watch it if it's on hbo max hbo
max coming in hot they are the [ __ ]
maybe the best streaming service it is
so good now you know i'm a hula boy
you know i'm a hula boy because i love
[ __ ] uh
what's his name the [ __ ] um
gif ramsay gordon ramsay yes dude i got
the name quicker than i normally would
because i went from [ __ ] 300
milligrams of gabapentin and i [ __ ]
weaned it back to 200 milligrams of
gabapentin and then last night i took
100 milligrams of gabapentin if i didn't
then guess what dude i would still not
know that his name was gordon ramsay but
i got it dude my mind's back my mind's
back so um
so i'm watching this show and and and uh
on hbo max hbo backs really be coming on
to some [ __ ] hot [ __ ] dude
they really be putting out some high
shed
if you i'm actually putting it with
gamora hbo max they're putting it with
uh that that [ __ ] one um generation
hustle
they'd be really putting out some hot
shed
they put it 15 minutes of shame could
only watch about 20 minutes of it
because it was triggering but they
really put out some hot [ __ ] dude
and i'm [ __ ] loving it man but i'll
tell you this though this show gamora
this is how the italians do it first of
all the shots are beautiful second of
all it's like she's
we're watching the first season and she
was just like why is everybody like
what's going on they're just killing
people shooting them in the head and i
go like this it clicked i go like this
you know what it's like it's like game
of thrones only my type of [ __ ] because
it's with italianos and not [ __ ]
dragons
you know what the first season of gamora
and the first season of game of thrones
have in common no dragons dude
you understand oh game of thrones that
show about dragons really watched three
season
where the [ __ ] dragons
okay if the show's about dragons have
the dragons up front dude like i always
say
put a [ __ ] demon in it man and hurry
it up i'm sick of watching these [ __ ]
movies that are either feel good or
about some woman finding themselves
and they're just like at a campsite for
[ __ ] two and a half hours and you
gotta watch it like [ __ ] beezerbubs
not in this movie and you gotta watch it
hollywood's really playing itself but
let me tell you dude hollywood italy
forget it i'm watching gamora and dude
here's what the [ __ ] italians do
first of all this [ __ ] is
so
bro it's
this is the thing
that that they really do really well
first of all
everyone
you think someone's a main character
that they're all of a sudden not a main
character and a matter of fact in the
first season they think somebody's a man
you think so oh this guy's going to be a
good guy he's really charismatic you
like the guy boom he's off you're like
okay don't know what the show's going to
be about but already you've jumbled up
my expectations all right so these
italians are looking at each other
talking to each other
from
and you're just sitting there okay
four or five or six episodes in
the main character has to go to honduras
honduras to try and [ __ ] do some [ __ ]
he basically is not in the show for two
episodes the main character leaves to go
to honduras to try to figure out a deal
with this [ __ ] the the the other
italian mafia family then he comes back
in two episodes and let me tell you
something dude he comes back in two
episodes
he is a different person he is so he's
he's lost a bunch of weight like this
guy just did it in what well how long
does it take to do an episode nine days
so that's 18 days in 18 days the guy
lost like [ __ ] 35 pounds came back
with a mohawk and stubble and the dude
looked hot as [ __ ] and and he was a
different person now this italiano
what's his name dude the lead in [ __ ]
gamora i don't know but i follow him on
instagram and he is so [ __ ] good
all of these actors are so good and
guess what dude none of them are [ __ ]
crying that's the kind of acting i want
to do i want to be in a real drama with
zero crying everyone's always crying in
the american dramas dude [ __ ] all that
bottle it up
and italianos are the most emotional
[ __ ] people on the planet but when
they're acting they bottle it up
gentlemen
oh your [ __ ] husband died
oh what happened your kid flunked out of
college
oh what happened you lost your legs
that's it dude bottling it up and guess
who bottles it up even more dude the
[ __ ] women dude
just walking in all buxom when their
husbands dying
they don't give a [ __ ] man boxing me
[ __ ] butt bottled
up it's insane
gamora really behind
so he comes back he's practically a
different person he's acting different
but you still believe it that's how good
of an actor he is it's not like when an
actor comes back and he's doing it too
much right like if an actor goes away
for a season then comes back in a season
and he's a changed man in america you'd
be like well he changed too much but
this dude did it so subtly but also
losing weight but doing it subtly but
also having a mohawk but doing it subtly
but also going out the [ __ ] six
o'clock shadow but also doing it subtly
and all of a sudden this guy's the
[ __ ] guy who's gonna be taking over
the whole [ __ ] the family and it's
beautiful dude but the thing i like
about it too
is that the sh the show is
gray as [ __ ] now i'm i'm not gonna it's
sepia my babies it's practically sepia
right
but i'm telling you right now okay
here's the thing a lot of times movies
will be sepia and i hate it
a lot of times movies will be the
nashville filter on instagram and i hate
it right a lot of times
movies will definitely be the [ __ ]
valencia filter on instagram and your
boy will hate it
but the italians made this [ __ ] sepia
and gray a little bit and what did they
do [ __ ] eight episodes in
what did they do episode eight episodes
in everyone does everyone know italianos
you know what you're doing if you like
because it was a very very big show it
was a very big hit in in italy what did
they do the guy [ __ ] says why is it
all gray outside
the guy says why is it all grey outside
they owned their [ __ ] they really came
through dude they really came through
that's the thing dude it's like when
[ __ ] aquaman is in other movies the
guy jason momoa
aquaman's in so many movies and not once
in any of the movies that jason momoa is
in
somebody stops and says holy [ __ ]
you're [ __ ] huge
why wouldn't you do that
he's huge he's obnoxious looking he's
built like a genie
hey dude he's got pubic hair
cascading out over his eye over his head
dude starting at his eyebrows [ __ ]
poofing out straight
swooping up along over his head and
cascading down his [ __ ] mountain
ridge and nobody's mentioning it
he's just some guy in a convenience
store in a movie nah
in italiano if jason mo mo moaini was in
a [ __ ] movie dude oh forget it dude
he'd walk in and it ties with don jenna
banjo what are you doing you're so big
what are you doing we got to take a not
only do you have the masters go side to
side they go up
what is going on and then he dies and
everyone just goes
they don't give a [ __ ] because they
bottle it up
and you guys sit out there and [ __ ]
listen to npr dude
live my whole [ __ ]
it's just like come on dude
these [ __ ] american shows and
everyone wants me to watch succession
and they're [ __ ] showing me gamora
dude and gamora comes up and they're
[ __ ] popping [ __ ] family
members in their heads dude like it's
going out and getting a reese's peanut
butter cup the [ __ ] out of town dude i
gotta get more italian i swear to god
i'm gonna get [ __ ] shirts that are
too small for my upper body and then a
jacket that's even smaller for my upper
body that's the most [ __ ] italian
thing you could possibly do is wearing a
[ __ ] shirt that's too small but a
jacket over the shirt that's too small
that's even smaller than the shirt dude
and your and even if you don't have a
belly this [ __ ] still pops out it's like
you'd look better naked but even still
you're [ __ ] popping out looking like
a stay puft like you looking [ __ ]
you're looking like the [ __ ] the the
guy who comes at the end of the
ghostbusters movies
and just [ __ ] long
genie shoes with a buckle on it
such bad style but [ __ ] will they cap
each other
oh man and [ __ ] this guy is in it and
he's bald and he's rocking the bald look
and my brother and i texted uh
to the group chain i said hey look vin
dieselini is in it and i [ __ ] laughed
i left for about i left just on and off
until i went to sleep that night vin
dieselini
vin diesel is not about if your friends
are your family vin dieselini
he's good though dude [ __ ]
[ __ ] i want to do one of those [ __ ]
real goddamn you know what dude i don't
even need hollywood i want to go to
italy and just become a [ __ ] good i
need to learn the language
god
none of you i love how listening this
podcast
none of you have watched this show and
i'm still talking about it 14 minutes
into this [ __ ] podcast and you're
still the people are listening that are
still listening even though you have no
reference point to what this show is
you're still listening and those are the
[ __ ] homies dude that's who's
in this cult those are the babies dude
and we're gonna be sitting in high grass
dude let's not forget that this is a
cult all right
we share this podcast with other friends
like the mormons do we go door to door
knock knock knock knock knock and we say
hello i'd like to talk to you about that
and then we don't say the church of
jesus christ of latter-day saints but we
say here's a link to congratulations i
hope you enjoy it dude and we hope we
hope that they join us in the tall grass
and they sit outside of a [ __ ] log
cabin and we share ideas
so yeah dude it's like
go watch gamora if you have hbo max i
don't give whatever or don't or don't
it's all good
i was scrolling instagram the other day
as you know as we do
and i came up on this
this is where we're at
this is how this speaks a lot to how
confused i am
and also where we are
in this ridiculous world but also i
don't want you to forget that i'm i'm
taking the blame on some of this like
this isn't just
this isn't just weird uh this isn't just
me complaining about the world it is not
this is how fast the world is moving
and how 41 years old i am okay
so
i am watching i'm scrolling through
instagram
and i find on instagram
um
this thing this picture that hypebeast
posts
um
[Music]
and it's
and it's this uh scooter
or not scooter what is it like a what's
the elon musk
quad is it a quad quad
elon
musk
it's and it's and it's being sold for
no not that not the
yes yeah the quad thing yeah the quad
thing whatever the [ __ ] right okay now i
see just a picture of this cyberquad
electric atv and it's supposed to be uh
yeah so i see this picture and it says
you can buy it for 1900 bucks
and i look at it and
i'm
looking at this picture and it's got a
black background and it looks so
futuristic you know it looks like
something that belongs in demolition man
that you'd watch in the 90s and you'd be
like
wow are they really gonna make those one
day and then here it is on my instagram
page and i'm like oh you can buy it
though and then i'm like
oh and i'm looking at it and dude i had
to
get out of the app and google
google it because i wasn't sure by
looking at the instagram picture and by
reading the description
if it was a [ __ ] nft or not
like i we're at the point in the world
where i'm looking at something that that
they are saying you can purchase and i
don't even know if it's a tangible thing
anymore
how unbelievable is that
guys who are even older than me
like if i brought this up to my dad he
would be like oh would you see it on
friendster like he wouldn't even
understand
he barely understands instagram and then
i'm doing all sorts of [ __ ] research
and looking at this [ __ ] metaverse
and [ __ ] and it's like okay
so i buy a nice shirt think about this i
buy a nice shirt say it's three thousand
dollars i've never spent that much on a
shirt but i buy a shirt that's three
thousand dollars
and i wanna wear it and i wanna wear it
where i don't wanna wear it at home i
wanna wear it out why because it's nice
and i want people to see it and i want
people to know that either you know if
i'm of a certain mind either that i have
money or i have fashion sense or that i
know what's hip any one of those things
maybe some even maybe i just think it
makes me look slender whatever the [ __ ]
it is right
now there's the metaverse
where what's his name uh travis scott
had a uh uh uh a show there and like 25
000 people came but they went with their
like
they just went to this web 3.0 and they
just watched the concert on travis scott
is doing on the internet so they weren't
actually there but they all bought
tickets and they can be like yeah i was
at that concert that's what they're
[ __ ] doing nowadays right this is the
first time that they did it i think but
people can we're getting to the point
where you can buy outfits
for your avatars or your um you can go
into some of these video games you can
literally buy outfits for some of your
characters that you're manipulating in
the video game right and there are
uh monetary values on each one of those
uh outfits you could buy a shirt for
whatever i don't know what they're going
for but 60 or 80
now you'll be why would you buy anyway
it's not really you but okay you want to
flex on the people that are in the game
which are essentially the people that
are playing the game
so i go back to me buying that shirt
that's in fashion or expensive and i
wear it on stage so people will know
i take a picture of that and i put it on
instagram now you have two million
people that follow me that see that i
have that shirt right and they say me
and that shirt a lot of those people
i'll never meet i'll never have a
conversation with they'll never meet me
they'll never have a conversation with
me but they see i'm at a certain level
right
i'm at this level
if you buy one of these quad these cyber
quads how many people are going to see
you riding around them you're going to
feel a little bit cool because you're in
a cyber quad maybe you're a tech geek
but maybe you just want it to have it
we're all buying these things because of
the extension of who you are now which
is fine so when i started to think about
it like that i'm like this
metaverse
is [ __ ] on to something i didn't
understand nfts but why not buy
something that doesn't exist
why the [ __ ] not
most money especially if you have it is
electronic anyway you don't [ __ ] see
it you don't hold it so what's wrong
with [ __ ] bitcoin what's wrong with
these people saying oh yeah but the the
the [ __ ] coins are gonna crash
maybe maybe not people bought a [ __ ]
pet rock in the what was it the 80s they
sold the pet rock and the only reason
why they were able to sell it is because
people were buying it and there will
always be those people and we call them
goodis here but we all have a little bit
of kuda in us man those barracudas snap
to those shiny objects they can't wear
them
a barracuda can't wear a [ __ ]
bracelet but they'll snap at one
that's who we all are man
we are all barracudas in the metaverse
and that
is some really deep [ __ ]
and i'm not the first person to think of
it this is why this whole thing [ __ ]
exists
the metaverse
everyone can be everywhere any given
time in this web 3.0 and that is [ __ ]
on
absolutely unbelievable now let's give
it a really subtle
really calm
breathtaking
[Music]
and i took a sip too but that's [ __ ]
crazy huh
people are flexing on instagram
they're flexing on tick tock
for all we know uh
carly
did giorgio what the [ __ ] her name on
the [ __ ] always doing that renegade
dance charlie demilio dimilio
sisters right
they
are don't exist i don't know have you
ever seen them
some of these people they don't dude
i've i saw a somebody on instagram once
and i you know i saw people were
following them oh you're so [ __ ]
beautiful you're so good they don't
it came out they don't exist dude it was
somebody that was made it was a
rendering of of of of a person that they
made and and it wasn't even a real
person and people are out there some of
them don't know but some of them know
and they're still like they're beautiful
i don't give a [ __ ]
it's really wild
are you gonna get a cyber uh quad i'm uh
i
i want to get one
i want to get one you do oh it's sold
out yeah no i know but they'll make more
it's sold out immediately of course it
sold out immediately but they'll make
more dude i never get the [ __ ] when it
first comes out anyway i can't be the
guy that's [ __ ] waiting at that i
don't even get like on the nike apps i
don't even i've never i've never won i
never won on because i'm always too late
i'm like
i'm like at least 10 minutes late and
it's like oh it's sold out four days ago
i'm like but it just came out 10 minutes
ago um but yeah dude
everybody wants
elon musk got the doug haircut huh you
saw that
he just saw that [ __ ] he got that
doug haircut elon musk just said save
the shave the sides
like he was in [ __ ] like it like you
know who did that the [ __ ] lead
character in gamora that i was talking
about earlier
he just cut it dude that's awesome to
cut your hair like that everyone makes
fun of it but who gives a [ __ ] he's
basically kanye but they're all the same
dude kanye west just got a [ __ ]
haircut he cut zigzags into his whole
[ __ ] head
and and elon musk was like i got you let
me let me one-up it i'll cut all the
sides off
that's it
it's bonkers
you see this seth rogen movie that's
coming out the [ __ ] uh
um
christmas movie
that's claymation where it's about two
this is how just backwards and like dude
i think you know seth rogen's funny and
[ __ ] and like the [ __ ] stuff he makes
he makes some good movies this is like
no knock or anything like that but i
just think that once you're in that
hollywood machine you start doing things
and just doing them like i always say if
you become too much of who you are
then that's bad if people are just
yesing you then that's just
and you're getting everything from it
you lose sense of who you are it's like
um
it's like uh uh how i always say uh you
know nicholas cage when he first started
he was just like oh you know and then
later on he just now he's just oh and
everyone's like he's a bad actor but
he's not he's earned the right to get
that but also no director was telling
him to shut the [ __ ] up and stop doing
that so how could you blame him right
it's not nicholas cage's fault i happen
to [ __ ] watch him because he's really
eccentric and i love him but it's like
my point is you got to have people in
there that [ __ ] check you you got to
have friends that'll be like what are
you doing
dyeing your hair purple or whatever the
[ __ ] it is right you got to check these
[ __ ] otherwise you're just yes
good job yes good job good job and they
become roar and then they're that
[ __ ] version of their roar and it's
like oops too late
too late it's like [ __ ] rampage and
they're crying climbing on buildings now
so my point is
i think this was this movie for [ __ ]
seth rogen he does this movie that is a
claymation movie about christmas
christmas which is fine
but then it's like
hey why can't a girl be santa claus and
this girl comes along and she's like i
want to be santa claus but so far santa
clauses have only been old white men and
it's like
is this for kids and they say [ __ ] it
a lot so who's going to watch it adults
it's claymation who's going to watch it
adults claymation and it's a christmas
movie you're not going to want i'm not
going to watch it with cap
who is it for
so you got seth rogen playing the santa
and then the the the girl like i want to
be santa too and i'm sure she becomes
santa by the end of the show but it's
like you could be santa if you want to
anyone could be santa if you want to now
here look i don't give a [ __ ]
if santa is a woman i don't care if
santa's a small one small person i don't
care if santa's black i don't give a
[ __ ] you know why santa's not real but
my point is
these people are just making movies to
i shouldn't say these people i should
say hollywood is making movies that fits
an agenda that tries to make this
these 10 000 people happy because they
don't want to be [ __ ] taken down and
you can't do that because the majority
doesn't give a [ __ ] the majority is not
going to watch your [ __ ] and the
majority is going to be like but santa's
why
now santa doesn't exist she's not white
black or asian or indian or whatever the
[ __ ] it is
but it's like
you can't make everybody happy and if
you try to you're just gonna fail and
that's why the movie has one percent on
rotten tomatoes or whatever the [ __ ] is
my point
also
they say that
if you're i mean they were getting mad
at the lady that that played harriet
tubman because she was british
she was a black woman but she was
british and they were like oh what does
she know she's not an american black
woman so now it's getting so specific
but then they [ __ ] let a jewish
person be santa claus
which is again fine by me i don't give a
[ __ ] but if you're gonna adhere to the
rules then adhere to the [ __ ] rules
if you made the rules fit in the rules
you can't make the rules and then all of
a sudden sidestep the rules like your
[ __ ] neo
you're not the one [ __ ]
it's silly it's silly it's [ __ ] silly
that's why i'm every day happier and
happier that you [ __ ] listen to me
and i got no [ __ ] agenda dude i'm
just chilling
i'm just chilling sign up for my patreon
patreon.com or don't dude i'm chilling
i'm [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm in the chill zone
dude
and people like oh he was canceled i
posted tick tock weren't you canceled
yeah now what
i'm chilling dude so i posted a [ __ ]
tick tock somebody said weren't you
canceled i said yeah now what and then
everyone wrote oh that didn't go how you
planned huh to the other person who
commented on me and they got so [ __ ]
insecure that they deleted my comment to
their comment but left theirs up dude
internet tko
[Music]
dude
just be yourself
be yourself
don't change who you are don't be who
you think you're gonna be
right that was my problem i wanted to be
the person that everyone was
thinking i should be right
not anymore dude
not calvin's dad that's not that
[ __ ]
i was getting everything in the [ __ ]
uh that that the industry gives you
and
i was becoming a certain way that i
thought right
i was living that crazy life dude and
now
i'm calvin's dad dude that's it i don't
give a [ __ ] that's why i say i'm in the
chill zone you understand i played with
my son all day
we did all sorts of crazy [ __ ] like i
had a fan i put a ball on top of the fan
the ball was spinning around floating
and he was like getting so excited i
pointed the fan at the ball the balls
went rolling
i [ __ ] he he he took he took mommy's
[ __ ] study sheets that are about that
big and and he and um
you know she's in therapy school and she
and he took uh he took those pieces of
papers and he was like that that that
and he ran over he tried to put him on
the tree and i was like you know what
you're doing you're decorating the
[ __ ] christmas tree just like i was
dude he was putting all sorts of [ __ ]
study papers on the [ __ ] christmas
tree walking around he couldn't do it so
he go how how how dude do you think i
did it for him do you think i did it for
him oh that would be what a good dad
does sure but i didn't i handed it back
to him and i said you can do it he cried
a little bit and then he [ __ ] put it
and it worked dude
that's the chill zone
that's the [ __ ] chill zone so when
somebody comes to me
and they want to say hey chris do you
want to voice a cartoon whale and
[ __ ]
glover donald glover's in it i go
i'm actually all good though
i'm in the chill zone
if you're you nobody can take that away
from you dude
nobody could take away
you being you
they can take away you being the idea of
you
but you're you dude
god damn it i hope you [ __ ] listen
and i hope especially you listen if
you're a [ __ ] gen z or dude i just
i see everybody you know it's like this
is the thing i see is like oh yeah what
do weak times make we times make [ __ ]
uh uh a weak people make hard times
and then
hard times make
uh strong people and then strong people
make [ __ ] um
good times and it's a cycle right and
it's been that way for uh hundreds of
thousands of years and [ __ ] uh
somebody posted on instagram the other
day but it was so it's [ __ ] true dude
and right now we are in the situation of
the [ __ ] weak people
and the hard times the weak people make
the hard times and we're we're [ __ ]
we're forging ahead though dude
and i say we because it's all of us it's
you and me man if you're a [ __ ] you're
still in this
you're gonna become one of the strong
[ __ ] or you fall to the wayside
and i hope you do i hope if you do you
have a good time in the [ __ ]
metaverse because that's all anyone's
gonna give a [ __ ] about you in
this guy i get okay look
you guys
told me i should make fun of the island
boys i didn't want to but i did it went
[ __ ] stupid viral all right put it on
tik tok i made like 25 in one day on
tick tock from the [ __ ] creator
account all right crazy [ __ ] i was
making stacks and going dummy viral
because did what you asked for now this
is the other thing that i get asked to
make fun of all the time i have not seen
this video yet but i know the name of
the guy because people keep writing him
to me his name is jeremy fragrance i
have no idea what his deal is i think
that he's like a guy who sprays cologne
on himself or something and i didn't
really i think i saw a clip of a video i
didn't really love it but i'm gonna
watch this one because one fire says i
have to say it okay
and the last one i don't talk so much
about is
perry alice 360 rats i love it man it's
the dildo of the fragrance industry okay
so hold on this guy
rates fragrances is that the deal
yeah okay and he's got so many colognes
in the back shelf like so many [ __ ]
colognes like it looks like a cologne
store maybe he has a cologne store i
have no [ __ ] idea but if you haven't
seen this guy and you're just listening
to this uh podcast you don't need to
google him because you know what he
looks like exactly how you're imagining
him okay so we did that
so we did that and if you're watching we
have a little picture for you so here we
go and this is what he is now let me
just start this over okay is the dildo
of the j he doesn't even use the [ __ ]
analogy right like he's saying it
because it looks like a dildo
what he should be saying is if you spray
it on yourself it makes it makes the you
know the down south region get a little
bit plentiful but he doesn't say that
and the last one i don't talk so much
about is
perry alice 360 rats i love it man it's
the dildo of the fragrance industry
and
yeah it's not so funny actually
still don't know how to talk about the
topic of masturbating uh wasn't
uh
wasn't yeah so about this fragrance it's
really nice it's long and it looks like
a [ __ ] boy do i i don't know how to talk
about masturbating
hey
he hit it head on nobody was even
[ __ ] with you dude this is a
monologue
and the third line in you're talking
about the thing that you don't want to
be talking the worst imagine him as a
bank robber
well i certainly didn't do it with
daniel
uh can we get daniel in no no i said he
i said we didn't he doesn't own two guns
and they're not under his bed
let's start it over again i mean jesus
christ dude guess if his [ __ ] button
his shirt is buttoned down way too much
and has a cross last one i don't talk so
much about is
perry ellis 360 reds
already devolving it's the dildo of the
fragrance industry
and
yeah oh boy so funny
still don't know how to talk about the
topic of masturbating
difficult man i i do it but i don't come
why
is that that early
i do it and i don't come
why offering that up hey guy
figure it out though
by yourself
hey guy
this is uh the world wide web
and you're just hawking fragrances this
isn't only fans
this is this is not pornhub let's just
roll in just
the roller coaster of this ride
how hot it starts below the ground and
how it just scoops up just talks so much
about is
perry
i love it man it's the dildo of the
fragrance industry
and
yeah it's not so funny actually
still don't know how to talk about the
topic of masturbating that's fine it's
difficult man i i do it but i don't come
and you know it's just like if i can be
that honest but
it's simply to boost my
power type of vibe
all right ultimately of course i want to
have a girlfriend
and a wife
turning that girlfriend into a wife and
have great kids
so that's perry alice 360 red
dude perry ellis 360 red [ __ ]
[ __ ]
bro the [ __ ] sails off the charts
after this guy so here's the perilous
360 red uh it is a great great fragrance
uh it is the dildo oops of it is the
dildo of the oopsie shouldn't have
brought that up uh actually silly me i
really get uncomfortable talking about
masturbation so i don't want to do that
i actually it's funny it's not even
really that funny i want to um
i do so
since we're on the topic i do masturbate
but i don't come
um
but yeah it's actually
makes it it's for the power you know it
makes me to get power to have a
girlfriend um and
then eventually have a wife and turn the
girlfriend into the wife
and they have great
great kids um so that's that's the
fragrance like
worst qvc guy
i'd rather be the guy who falls down the
ladder and breaks his [ __ ] disks
wow this guy's unreal and this guy left
it up was it live
let's listen to the whole thing again
how did he do it
how do you do it and the last one i
don't talk so much about is
perry ellis 360 rats are you printing
something out you
wha why are you printing [ __ ] out for oh
my god dude
she's printing [ __ ] out all right well
it's going
all right well this is a bad time to do
it
just just get it
just because the odds are hot it's going
like that during the [ __ ] podcast i'm
trying to do i'm in i'm in the middle of
a killer bit and kristen
the printer what was i even talking
about
oh god let's play this let's replay this
one last time
just to [ __ ] get the full-fledged
[ __ ] thing no pauses no breaks
and the last one i don't talk so much
about okay so what happened was we cut
because kristen had to [ __ ] print
something out for her presentation which
i had no idea was which piss which
pissed me off but it's all good learning
how to control my anger and therapy all
good got the techniques
and the techniques really do be hidden
right now so it's all good and the last
one i don't talk so much about is
perry alice 360 rats i love it man it's
the dildo of the fragrance industry
worst and just stop right there it's not
so funny actually
still don't know how to talk about the
topic of masturbating
difficult man why do i do it but i don't
come and oh that part is the real
that part is the real [ __ ] banger
right there
i don't like it it's weird enough to be
like i talk i i feel weird talking about
masturbation we're like okay yeah we get
it he's like you know i do it but i i
and i don't come and we're just like who
the [ __ ]
like what is it practice isn't
masturbation practice
for sex
and this guy's just practicing to
practice
it's like those annoying guys in the
[ __ ] on deck circle it's like you
know how to swing what are you warming
up yeah i guess this guy's warming up i
do it and i don't come
wow dude that guy was so
um
so that's what's up that's what's been
going on here's another video from the
guy
oh this guy yeah does this have music on
it though
you do five sprays
one oh boy here we go how to apply a
fragrance you do five sprays
one behind each ear okay all right one
in front of your neck on your clothes
that's two but and one on the back of
your neck i mean so because if you walk
around you have a nice central behind
you you can spray this spot right here
you can spot
this right here but i don't suggest you
for different reasons that i mentioned
in other videos
oh my god
the way uh first of all sprayed his
literally it was like five different
places to spray
all five were on the neck
imagine like being a girl and like then
like making out with him and like
kissing his neck and just tasting a
[ __ ] department store
i hate there's no there's no cologne
there's only perfume
guys who wear
perfume it's just off dude
i go back to this date my day when i was
in high school and my uncle picked up
one time he picked up me and my buddy
and me and two other buddies
and one of them had cologne on and we
were driving for like 10 minutes and my
uncle was driving he said all right
who's killing me with the cologne
and honestly i swear to god his name was
jeremy but it's not jeremy fragrance
it's a different jeremy he said all
right who's killing me with the cologne
he had to open the [ __ ] windows he
must apply these five [ __ ] spritzes
wand on the neck one on the front of the
neck one on the side of the neck one on
the side of the neck and then one on the
back so you leave a cent trail
guys
just let me smell your pheromones
men women let me smell your pheromones
because some people are just very very
very
bad smelling and i want to know that you
know what i mean
talk about being who you think you
should be i want to know that i get it
deodorant is all good put it under the
thing like i wear natural scented
deodorant because your boy's all natural
dude i've got no implants
i [ __ ] use as minimal types of smell
shits as i need to
i got the nioxin shampoo keeping the
hair thick as [ __ ]
right
i got nioxin level four keeping it thick
as [ __ ]
because i don't want the [ __ ] to go bald
because everybody goes bald right mostly
even chicks be losing their hair when
they're older but i'm trying to keep my
my [ __ ] to the fullest maximum chia pet
effect so i got the nioxin [ __ ] and this
[ __ ] doesn't smell too much it smells
fine
i take the [ __ ] uh i forget what
deodorant i have but it's all natural
yeah it's a little bit powdery but it
doesn't have aluminium in it you
understand it has no aluminum in it
because your boy he doesn't want those
chemicals chemicals unless of course
he's eating lots of ice cream at night
but he doesn't want you know i ate a
little bit of gummy bears the other day
but i don't normally eat candy that's
processed in a lab i mean all candies
processed in a lab but you know what i
mean at least a lot of this candy that i
eat i mean not really can't i don't eat
candy but like i eat stuff that's
actually food you know
like gummy bears and sour worms they
don't make it to my diet mostly it's
chocolates and stuff and maybe some
cakes whatever a cookie here and there
but um
don't be yeah
i keep it really natural dude because
that's me i'm trying to be me to the
fullest effect like i told you i'm
trying to be calvin's dad i'm not trying
to be i am
it's like my dad always said my dad
would say i say when did you want to be
a director when did you know you want to
be a director and make movies and he
said
i i had to find out i was a director
right he always says this type of thing
like popeye doesn't want to be popeye
papaya is popeye
and that's the [ __ ]
but it's hard for people to realize when
they're popeye
especially when you be spraying [ __ ]
five
drop
dude we in our cult we don't wear
[ __ ] we don't wear perfume or cologne
no bs dude no no [ __ ]
my tmj really [ __ ] hurts that's cool
push this one spot
in my uh jaw
and uh
it hurts a lot really badly
it's literally in my ear so it feels
like i have an earache it's unbelievably
you guys with tmj disorder know what i'm
talking about dude if you push the area
right before your ear
forget it
it's absolutely [ __ ]
and then i open it and it unlocks a
little bit but i can't keep it unlocked
and it locks back down so that's great
where my tmj dysfunction babies
um
to this thing here
i was
just checking out the news here
oh
this is from the av club
a dancing cactus toy that raps in polish
about cocaine withdrawal has been pulled
from sale
in walmart canada
this is the weirdest [ __ ] thing
walmart puts
pulls
[ __ ] it um
that swears in polish and sings
i just
how did honestly
there
there's gotta be drugs in this thing
like
this is what it says the only thing in
my head is five grams of cocaine fly
away alone to the edge of oblivion oh my
god dude in polish i have thoughts in my
head when will all this end whenever i'm
not alone because a white eel will fly
in
what dude
oh my god dude first of all there's got
to be drugs in this thing because this
none of this makes any sense there's no
cactuses cacti in poland
or canada
this comes from poland
and is being sold or it speaks polish
it's being sold in canada
to kids
kids don't even know what a [ __ ]
cactus is in canada it's all [ __ ]
snowy and [ __ ] up there it needs to be
the driest of deserts and this thing's
like hey kids
try not to do so much goddamn cocaine
or you'll be on the edge of oblivion
it'll never end this white eel will fly
it up my [ __ ] nose
walmart's canada says the dancing cactus
was sold by a third party and that it's
been removed from the online store
considering that this is the same
retailer that previously brought us a
sweater with a bug-eyed santa claus
ripping lines on it we imagine it's only
a matter of time before walmart canada
delivers us another delightful
game-related schedule what
walmart would no longer allow us to
enjoy its wack and walk cocaine santa
claus sweater
this is when was this dude
this was
the 2019
wow santa it has a [ __ ] in walmart to
do it [ __ ]
it looks like a a white snowy santa
ripping snow cocaine with a [ __ ]
straw
and their lines of [ __ ]
at walmart
this is amazing in the long pop culture
tradition excuse me almost throw up of
santa claus doing inappropriate things
pissing himself
between hearing children's wish lists
murdering innocent people in any number
of holiday themed slashers a sweater
showing the jolly old fella racking up a
few lines of cocaine and all this is
like a very big deal you know all the
same walmart canada what's up [ __ ]
walmart canada hey walmart canada
check
check your goods
well also why does it always have to do
with cocaine
so [ __ ] weird
the sweater's
description let's look at the sweater's
description
oh they took it down god damn it okay
they took it down of course they took it
down
god damn that's amazing
dude the world's nuts that's awesome
this is something that would happen in
the 80s and kids would have it and they
would grow up and they'd be like
[ __ ] uh cactus and you know was
rapping about [ __ ]
uh doing coke right they'd be like oh
yeah i had the sweater
oh yeah i'm realizing that now the kids
will grow up they'd be fine they'd be
tough
they'd be tough but now we got like all
these nah take it from the shelves and
now we're we're making everyone weaker
you need those [ __ ] you need those
fuck-up toys you know you need those
toys that [ __ ] you up
this [ __ ] hurt when you fell down now
everything's all padded
oh man
you know what i'm saying
[ __ ] used to be dangerous toys used to
be dangerous as [ __ ] they used to have
[ __ ]
cages out that you put babies in outside
of their window so they could get fresh
air in apartments in new york they'd
have a cage that was outside of the
window like an air conditioner and you
just put the baby in that cage and they
would just be out there [ __ ] chilling
look all those kids grow up they're
probably [ __ ] goddamn uh it's
probably elon musk
they create [ __ ] successful
[ __ ] that moved the society
forward and now you can't even get a
cocaine sweater at walmart
well
we're doing it to ourselves come on
walmart
all walmart had to do was be like yeah
we know what the cactus [ __ ] raps
about do you want it or not
that's what they should have done dude
that's what we need
oh man chris cuomo how about that for
being down to for his brother just kind
of like was like kind of on his side and
cnn was like can't have it
what you knew was gonna happen now
that's italian dude that's some
[ __ ] gamora [ __ ] for real this
motherfucker's like i'm gonna help you
but you know how many phone calls did
they have that were just like you know
we can't be [ __ ] tugging this can't
be nobody we gotta meet in person you
know they loved it secretly too because
they're italian the two cuomo's were
like we gotta meet in person don't tell
anybody we can't we gotta get off the
line are you talking like that on the
[ __ ] line
are you you can't be mentioning these
things on the [ __ ] line are you
kidding me meet me at [ __ ] washington
square park
meet me behind the [ __ ] dumpster
outside of race pizza which one is
[ __ ] a hundred thousand
are you saying that on the line
don german jordan
with comes back with a different haircut
and he's skinnier
[ __ ] is different dude the cornwall
brothers [ __ ]
yeah man
uh [ __ ] they're both out now they're
out they're out because somebody was
just like yo i did this happen
they're out no that's it that's it no
political career for [ __ ] either of
them and one of them can't be on cnn
anymore
it's crazy man what a crazy world people
just accused and you're gone
but yeah dude wow
thank god i'm not a politician huh
[ __ ] politicians or well [ __ ] you
know trump had a bunch nobody gave a
[ __ ]
[ __ ] is crazy dude yeah it's [ __ ] uh
you know what do you do if you're in
that situation just chroma because chris
chromos i know my brother i know he
wouldn't do that [ __ ] and so he wants to
help him but also he wants to keep his
job but ultimately fi just like vindel
vin diesel said it and just like vin
dieselini says it and thinks it in
gamora there's nothing stronger than
family dude and that's what i want you
to take home from this episode today
and just remember dude remain
you in that chill zone
that zone of ultimate maximum chill
right because if you aren't you're just
the idea of who you are you're not
who you truly are
hey guys that's it for the episode to
catch the rest of the episode and with
no ads and no commercials commercial
free uncut extra long episode and you
can sign up for our patreon
patreon.com it's just six bucks and also
there are back previous episodes that uh
you cannot access on youtube that are on
my patreon as well
every month we'll put a new one out
that is not available to the public
you're on our exclusive patreon
if you sign up today patreon.com makes a
good good christmas gift too so
thanks bye
[Music]
[Laughter]
congratulations
[Music]
thank you
difficult man i i do it but i don't come
and